hey what's up guys it's scarce here now
our first story of today comes from the
youtuber known as
edp 445. okay so edp 445 is a huge
youtuber he's over 2 million subscribers
i'm sure many of you have actually
watched his videos before a lot of
people looked up to him they thought he
was a really funny dude
but it turns out that he got exposed for
probably one of the worst things i've
ever seen
from any youtuber ever so for those who
don't know over the past year edp has
been exposed
multiple times for allegedly
inappropriately messaging
minors okay there was more than five
instances where people were saying that
edp was trying to get with
an underage person okay now obviously
this is a very serious
and edp himself even made videos respond
to the act
and he made a ton of support on these
videos now
was that my voice in the voice clips
yeah am i a pedophile
[ __ ] no gives me the [ __ ] heebie
jeebies my [ __ ] thinking about that
[ __ ] [ __ ] you feel me
do i have a [ __ ] up sense of humor
yeah you know what i mean i'm a crazy
ass [ __ ]
so there's been many actions made
against edp this year and recently a
youtube group known as predator poachers
has been completely blowing up okay now
these guys go after alleged predators
and what they try to do is they
set up a decoy and they have someone who
looks very young
to actually message this person and act
like they're a 13 year old girl
or however old this girl is and they try
to get this person to text them
and send them inappropriate pictures
pretty much trying to catch predators
okay it's kind of like chris hansen's to
catch a predator and one of the hosts of
predator poachers known as chet
goldstein has been doing this for a long
time now
he goes after different predators and
they've even gotten a lot of predators
charged
with very serious offenses so this group
got a ton of messages
from people's telling them to look into
edp okay they were telling him
look into this guy we're not sure if
he's done anything wrong but there are
so many accusations against him
you guys need to look into him and see
what the heck is going on here and what
they did is they set up a decoy a 13
year old girl
and edp responded to this girl almost
immediately after she messaged him on
instagram okay
so they started talking on instagram and
eventually this led to a text
they gave each other their phone numbers
and over time throughout this
conversation between edp and the miner
he gets more and more explicit he starts
mentioning doing intimate things with
her
to be honest we can't even show you guys
a lot of the messages here but they have
all the messages on their channel
predator poachers actually read almost a
two-hour long transcript of all the
messages that they sent
back and forth between edp and this
decoy that was messaging him okay and
when you look through these text
conversations between him
and this 13 year old girl you can see
that multiple times throughout this
conversation
he says that he is afraid of going to
jail at times when he regrets it he's
usually regretting it because he's
scared that he's going to go to jail
um or lose his channel things like that
he's not really regretting it
um because of the age you know he he
sometimes he'll like vaguely mention
that but you'll see that he
periodically mainly says that like i
don't want to go to jail like what if
you're the police stuff like that
so while adp sent many of these messages
of him trying to get intimate with this
girl
he'd also sent even more outlandish
messages to this girl where he says some
pretty
crazy things and predator poacher shows
here that he was apparently texting her
saying that he wants to climb through
the window into her house
to make out with her and he also says
that he wants to lock her up in his
dungeon
so towards the end of their text
conversation this 13 year old girl
decoy actually texted him telling him to
come over to her place
and they were actually meant to meet up
somewhere right outside an apartment
complex
okay and edp actually does show up to
this apartment complex here and predator
poachers even posted a 50-minute long
video
of their whole interaction after edp
tried to meet up with this girl
and you could tell he's extremely
nervous here because he knows how
serious this situation is
now adp claimed here that he was just
trying to get a cupcake but he very
quickly admits to a lot of the messages
and conversations
that he had with this 13 year old girl
and he actually admits to a lot of
things
in this video so again what made you
what made you
what made you start this conversation
with this said 13 year old
you said what you're doing right here
correct yes or no right okay go ahead
well she messaged me right
and uh she messaged me and um i'm not
going
to lie to you man you know what i mean
um sometimes you know
a person feels lonely and stuff and they
want the um
they want the the interaction okay you
know what i mean
are these guys cops i don't think these
guys no they're not
no they're not the thing that happened
and i saw the video i actually saw the
video the guy with the beard the redhead
and the other guy it's like
they come in and it's like yo we got
some questions for you and we know you
were meeting a 13 year old
and if you don't talk to us
we're gonna put all this whole thing to
the the authorities
that's how they do when you watch the
video of the interview
the guys are you know catching predators
so it's it's good like
they're catching predators that's a good
thing about the video but
when i sent a bit of clout was the
question
and how he's asking the question there's
a lot of pettiness in the questions
there's a lot of like he's trying to
there's a lot of jokes that are making
like
sarcastic jokes that they're making
about the this thing just to make him
look
and feel bad listen you're not the cops
he's not gonna feel bad it's gonna make
you feel bad
yes you're gonna put this on your on
your channel but that's pretty much
that's all there is to it or you talk to
us or you we're gonna
give all this information to to the
authorities and that's how he gets to
have a whole conversation with them but
the conversation is really off
it's really awesome they're going in
circle at some point he's just like
all right i'm done with this and he
starts to leave and he's like no no and
they run after him
with more questions that are super weird
like yes guys
yeah okay so this is why i'm not a big
fan of
vigilantism okay
so this whole thing that they've done is
not admissible in court they can't no
it's not just to put somebody behind
bars and so
no on one hand you're you can you can
somehow feel glad
you might feel a sense of relief because
you're like this person got
caught but all that really happened is
they lost their platform if this
person's likely to offend
and now they're just no longer be online
we won't know because
the fact that they won't be on the radar
you feel what i'm saying and now we're
just going to do it again but off the
radar
right right and so i think that's where
i have an issue with it because this is
not something that you should cancel
people for
hold on what did you say you said it's
not something that we should cancel
people for what we should be doing is
putting them behind bars
this is a consequence right you don't
cancel someone because
they sell drugs or whatever if they're
selling fentanyl whatever it is
get them behind bars you know what i'm
saying go through the proper channels
because now
any opportunity potentially i know the
cops are saying they're going to look
into this now but like
any opportunity for a criminal
investigation to be severely hampered
by these people interfering and doing
this you know
what you heard in the news is
interfering with that you can't try it
and that was also a problem with to
catch a predator a lot of the people who
were on to catch the predator didn't
ended up going to jail
because the way the investigations were
ran and the like setups it did
they weren't admissible in court and so
when i see these shows they might be
like
well we got one because everybody wants
to protect kids i think that's a valiant
cause
but just because you want to do
something doesn't mean you're doing
something that's smart you understand
what i'm saying
i think it's good that this person's
been exposed that people know that he's
a danger
and a fantastic but you also have to
consider not everyone watches youtube
right he comes back in a different name
in a different city with all the money
that he may have accumulated
there may be other opportunities for him
they can't do it personally i didn't
know who edp 445 was
right and so if he lives up in another
neighborhood like
that's it that's just one of the worries
worries that i have when i see this kind
of video
it's legitimate so that's just my
thoughts initially when i'm watching
this
okay so this isn't what happened because
she never said she was lonely right here
correct yes or no right
okay and you did double text here yes or
no correct knowing and it said honor
profile 13 yes correct okay
so you initiated a conversation with a
13 year old knowing she was 13 yes or no
correct okay
so is that why is he talking to this
dude like he's law enforcement
that's so weird yeah there's a lot of
weird in this video
it's like if he wanted to the man could
have just walked away at any point
and the dude couldn't have done anything
but the way
they are keeping him there is really by
saying
if you don't talk to us on our cam on
our video
and have this conversation we bring all
this to the cops so they're scared i
mean
i mean you know be glad that he was an
idiot and he made these moves but at the
same time it's like
anyone who has half a brain would not
even stain this kind of scenario
is that a good look for you no it's not
okay so
you've been exposed for this before
correct what i don't understand why you
why are you attracted to like 13 years
like why are you attracted to underage
because you clearly said
what what a stupid question you know
this is a very serious problem
and when people come at it like why are
you into this stuff listen
there are like people like this all over
the world and vast majority of them
don't
choose this attraction that they have
doesn't mean we should accept it
doesn't mean we should abide it they
should get help and if they offend they
should be put behind bars
everyone agrees with these notions but
when you come here and you're asking
like
why are you like i'm telling you that's
what
that's what i'm saying there's a lot of
weird [ __ ] that they were asking
and a lot of the way they were
formulating the question was like ah
i don't know why you're i don't know
what the purpose at this point is
in one of the screenshots that you've
always wanted to be with
someone younger are you like fantasized
about being with someone younger
and you're scared of being a sting
operation or a cops
like what goes through your head what
makes this okay for you because this is
disgusting
real man what goes on is
loneliness dude i'll be completely
honest with you man but you have
millions of followers
all right like how are you lonely you
have like millions of followers there
right there you know what i mean you
have millions like they're
so cringy this is so cringy and
unproductive in a weird way
yep i bet you there's chicks in your dms
trying to hit you up absolutely and
you're though you're here for a 13 year
old and eventually these guys start
talking about
all the different miners and underage
girls that edp was allegedly messaging
over the last few months
so again what's the ballpark number of
how many miners you talk to
like at you know obviously it's been
five so
after five what would you say the number
is six six sure
six miners name them um
now shortly afterwards edp even admits
here that he should be in jail the only
thing deterring you based on these
messages
it wasn't the fact she was young it was
jail time that was deterring you yes or
no
okay so say there's no law say we live
in an anarchy
you would have followed through with
this yes or no had you been able to
correct right
okay so so before you give i didn't want
to do anything
you did want to do something the intent
was there the only deterrent is jail
like for me well the intent is right
when you showed up here that's intense
right right shut up like doesn't get any
right like if the cops all these
messages that's all you hear where they
have arrested you yes or no
okay so look see you think you deserve
to go to jail
because you admitted this is not your
first time this is up to like sixth time
right this is your fifth or sixth time
do i deserve to go
to jail if i'm being honest with you
you don't think so i think so you think
so okay
do you want to go no so the conversation
between predator poachers and adp
lab you know i can't take any of these
answers seriously because like
i don't know what people think do you
think this is insightful
you know this is a person who you know
obviously needs help
should be behind bars whatever right and
you have this conversation with somebody
who clearly has like control over the
situation i'm going to expose you if you
don't do what i want
so all these answers are really
irrelevant because they're all from a
weird place of like
extreme fear i don't know i watch this
and maybe people think this kind of
stuff is entertaining or insightful but
when i'm watching this i'm just like
this is just awkward it's like pointing
a gun at someone's head and expecting
complete honest answers as they're
saying they're underneath the barrel
it's like yeah
you know this of course i don't know so
the conversation between predator
poachers and adp
lasts for about another half hour but
towards the end here
these guys should say they're going to
call the cops and you can tell edp
starts to get visibly upset you know he
is so upset here because he knows what
could happen to him
if he gets charged with this and while
these guys are calling the cops edp
actually walks away calls his friend up
saying that he's going to go to jail
and then gets in his car and drives away
so to be honest with you guys this is
the most serious story so i hear
something left up
what
[Music]
if this man goes to jail it might save
his life because yo once he gets on that
jail workout program to get like he
might just lose all that weight that's
probably going to kill him anyways
i think they might do him a favor by
sending this [ __ ] to jail
because judging by how those legs was
buckling no judging by how those legs
was buckling as this man was walking
high blood pressure and diabetes are
probably going to kill this man ever
before jail could no no
if he goes to jail he's going to get
shanked molesters and [ __ ] like that
they don't
they don't have a good rip i mean i
think that's how things
used to be or they used to be far more
relevant nowadays it depends on where
you get sent
it's not the same as it used to be back
in the day
it depends all this to say yeah well i
was just having this epiphany when i was
thinking about it involving a youtuber
on this channel i mean with five years
of making videos on this stuff i've
never seen something
so insane this guy was straight up
caught on camera and after this video
was released you had a ton of youtubers
and streamers that were just
so upset you know what's interesting is
people like this is the worst thing i've
ever seen on youtube et cetera except
i'm like
but think about all the people who never
got caught
yeah that's a [ __ ] thing man guess
what the people all the people that got
rich enough to get away
that's that's that's that's the that's
the real thing yeah
all the rich people that got away with
better at covering their tracks when it
comes to a lot of
stuff you know you know put the man
behind bars handle it
it's one of those things where he's like
yeah this is not a
hard one this person clearly was using
their platform to do some really weird
stuff
and get them behind bars because this is
someone who's clearly going to offend
and get them help get them help
because you know if you want to protect
kids you need to make sure when this
person comes out of jail
that they've been handled well enough so
that they when they come back out
because listen whether you like it or
not people can't go to jail for life
that's not the way it works these kind
of crimes maybe you want it that way
and so change the laws and make it so
but if you understand that this person
is going to get out eventually
you need to make sure that they get the
help that they need so they never engage
in this stuff
you know this is such a weird topic
because it involves the safety of
children i feel like when people have
these conversations i think they don't
know much about
the definitions of words how common this
is
how preliminate this is and also when
you talk about this stuff
it's really just emotions a lot of it is
and also how ineffective we've been at
protecting children from these things
and it's not stuff like this thing here
that's going to protect people this does
very little to protect people you know
because all it does
is it helps people who are already
thinking like this
to better cover their tracks yep right
because we've seen the incidence of kids
being you know fondled all this stuff
is rising it's not going down abductions
are not going down they're rising
so we have to come to terms society and
understand like we're not tackling this
issue intelligently when i see stuff
like this
it's just more evidence of
ineffectiveness when it comes to these
issues
when it comes to these issues maybe
we've done all this wrong all the time
all this time we've done we've been
wrong all this time you know yeah and i
don't want anyone to hear this like oh
these guys are trying to make it okay no
one's making it okay
listen it is absolutely traumatic and
terrible for kids to be involved with
anybody at this age
and so i would never think it should be
legalized or accepted or anything like
that
keep it off the streets absolutely
necessary what i'm trying to say is
we need to be more effective with how we
combat this issue because i'm telling
you
it's happening more now than ever and
now that these people get a bit of money
you know what they do
they just leave they go to a different
country they do their dirt over there
oh yeah go to some south asian countries
go to some european countries hell
preach where preachers worked at hotels
that we had to sign dnas
and you know what if you have enough
money ndas i'm sorry
ndas so so so i just want people to
understand this issue is far more
relevant than people think
and the way that we've been combating it
has been fairly ineffective
watching this this is the kind of
misguided effort
that i think people engage in that does
more harm than good long term
that's just my opinion maybe i'll
disagree and if you do i'm not mad at
you maybe you're right
uh but when i see this i'm like this man
it's not going to go to jail based off
of this
unless there's like other conversations
that these guys didn't infringe on
and weren't involved in i just don't see
this man going to jail for this because
they kind of tainted the whole
the whole the whole investigation that's
just how i think about it
what especially by putting it online and
putting on a web and having a
ob like yeah where are you gonna where
are you gonna find a jury of people that
then you know it's going to be very hard
it's going to be very hard yeah maybe
i'm wrong
i'm wrong maybe they maybe they've
successfully gotten people in jail and
i'm just unaware
but from what i've seen maybe and if
they have great
if they have great but that's the whole
way that
this whole thing was conducted was very
weird a lot of questions like it's like
okay you guys
it didn't seem like you were prepared or
you want it yeah it was weird the longer
version of the video is just
a cringe fest not because not because
edp 45 gets caught
not it's really because of questions the
questions are
like they don't make sense yo you it it
should have been
it really should have been you did this
you did that
you admit to this yeah all right
the rest casper
friendly ghost it's unnecessary it goes
right through me
the thing that happened is this is but
we have to acknowledge one thing though
okay the reason why this is happening is
because the just
people feel like the justice system is
not doing a good job and you know the
sentences are bad and stuff like that
and that leads to that that's the reason
why you see a lot of vigilante
you know what listen maybe i'm unaware
and maybe this stuff is more effective
than i'm aware
i would imagine just random people
getting involved generally doesn't bode
well for most investigations
but i also understand what you said you
made a great point in regards to them
feeling the justice system isn't doing
enough it's really hard to con to
convict anything
and when you have a good lawyer
sometimes just keep that so people
that have family members and people
close to them that's been hurt or just
plain out
people being hurt and they don't want
people to be hurt they feel powerless
and that's why we have vigilantes like
that so i do understand where it's from
you know i understand like there's
there's some problems in the
in the system so i'm not going to bash
the people
necessarily that are all the people that
are doing that there's a problem in the
system there is we cannot
we cannot go over that and be like
there's it is often
the more money you got the better the in
a better position you are to have
lawyers to be able to
swerve all of that and stuff you know so
i don't disagree with that i agree that
there is a problem i just don't think
this is necessarily the optimal solution
but hey i'm not even mad at them because
you know what what you said makes a lot
of sense so
yeah just one of those things where it's
just like you just want better solutions
to this and it just feels like the
people who should be handling this
aren't doing a good enough job but hey
these guys are doing a great thing
and they're getting these people behind
bars they're great i just um
the thing that i have is that when he's
talking about all these tactics and how
he does
to to catch them it's just really like
you're setting up a how to catch a
predator and
predators i'm pretty sure a lot of
predators watch these things and these
to know what's what to do and what not
to do
the police don't broadcast everything
that they do you know yeah i agree
all right well listen man listen i don't
know this is a very difficult topic
i don't even think we're going to cover
this but i was like what if i'll just
plug it in yeah whatever these were my
thoughts so
i didn't even think we were about to
cover that either so yeah yeah well
listen let us know what you guys think
in the comments below and uh
that's pretty much it for us
[Music]